here's uh punky johnson what's up
brandon what's up theo
quinn here from kc you already know
super bowl champs holding it down the
best athlete in the world patrick [ __ ]
in my homes
new orleans saints denver broncos ain't
going to win
[ __ ] anytime soon that's fair
nothing soon but [ __ ] man thanks for all
the positivity
a couple days ago man i tested positive
for uh covert 19.
uh it's been kind of a stretch you know
rough stretch here last couple days but
watching you guys man really helps me
man list my spirits man
i'm pushing through bro i'm gonna be all
right [ __ ] i got a debate club for you
when you were in elementary school dodge
ball or kickball
oh let's hear it gang gang buzz buzz
now i'm gonna throw a curveball at you
you ever played crazy kickball
where you kick the ball and you can go
to first or third and then you can just
stay on the base and you pile up and you
grab hands to get to the next base ooh
crazy kickball
it's good oh fantastic damn we didn't
have we had some more bootleg [ __ ] like
that we had looking for gold was a game
we played just looking for gold
outside um dude we had um
red rover was always dangerous dodgeball
depended on who came back to school that
day like some days we'd have a kid at
school that was 30 years old
and i was like this dude ain't supposed
to be here but his mama dropped him off
that day or something and he you know he
didn't he wasn't working or something
and you're playing dodgeball with the
grown man yeah so now you're like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
dave's gonna win yeah yeah yeah mr
allen's gonna win
you know and so sometimes that that was
the only thing about dodgeball was there
was no
check and balances system you know that
red rover red rover sent brendan right
over
oh i come [ __ ] bailing through that
lane doug
yeah my little fat ass just bailing
through [ __ ]
those are really good days running you
can't do that anymore running backwards
dude you can't do it anymore
vernon played basketball he was a power
backward
power back red rover red rover is the
original wedge breaker on kickoffs doug
oh yeah totally that's a good call dude
uh kickball was fun
though kickball was fun and you didn't
have to have all that extra equipment
you have to have the gloves in the
middle just the ball dog
and the baseball field dude we had one
kid on our baseball team we were 11. he
got out there he
couldn't afford a glove and he got out
there with a kitchen mitt hell yeah
and he was good too yeah a little like
kind of mixed guy
but yeah he was good man um i'll say
kickball dog and they you can't do
dodgeball schools anymore either because
they said they'd pick on kids
that's the game dog you got the fat kid
in the corner you light his ass up first
dude sometimes you're surprising
catching everybody come running in yeah
damn he couldn't wait you get hit he
just we're waiting
and then when you got hit and you're
walking you get hit in the face
i'm out stupid yeah that was the worst
bro when people would light somebody up
the worst one got hit in the face in
front of your crush oh your face be all
hot and red
like that even hurt and then your crush
is like
i'm a hymn you pretend to tie your
sandal
but i'ma say what time i sandle thanks
gene
[Music]